Hi, is Icelandic cod liver wild caught in can okay to eat once or twice a week?
Yes, I'd say yes.
You can eat that. You can buy wild caught salmon, you know,
lots of places, even by our local grocery store,
or Minnesota's come foods, they have wild caught salmon that's frozen,
that's actually fairly inexpensive compared to other, you know,
to go to whole foods or something like that.
But yeah, I know you could get, you know, there are,
there's argument that when you have canned foods, you could get heavy metals
or a little bit of it. I have never seen the studies on what,
if there are any in this particular product,
maybe you could Google it and buy it out.
But you could probably make an argument that there's heavy metals in this,
but every food that we eat.
And that's why you're not feeling stops,
unless you don't absorb these heavy metals in the foods that we eat.
But yeah, I would say anything within the race of the spine.